you could just have a little cookie i
mean just to dance
that's not what i demand
that's not what i meant truth
i was just thinking we should just play
some cards
okay
do you
i mean they're your cards what's you
what's your game i'm not really that
good at cards these cards are in your
house i know well it's more of a
training exercise it's stopped you
should see what i did with
a top game a 52 card pickup shot that's
the stupidest game ever it doesn't i'm
gonna teach you a real game
is that
glass a little shot glasses cleaning
that's filthy
i mean
clean them no no no no i got i got more
than that
hi baby hi
hi
i got a
i don't i've got a very cleanish glass
[Music]
that's completely unsanitary man i can
see you i'm right here
i'm gonna roll it on this lady's face
look at this is this what is this this
is your reading material yeah
[Music]
yeah i already read it though swept you
could borrow lives and loves of three
brothers on the windswept shores of
chesapeake bay
jax
i'm all right is that your heart no
nothing like that it's just it's just uh
i can't feel that side of the body jesus
christ man
here let me help you you want me help me
move help me sit up
all right we're getting
ready just this thing that happened it's
uh
it might be a little um
we're shaped in what i thought
geez you think so
i do
yeah um
jackson
it's like pins and needles
it's numb
yeah i don't even feel that right now
but it'll it'll come back
let me just
let me just uh
hey
yeah stay with right here you know it's
just like billy parham when he got
thrown in pompano it's uh you remember
how he was
he was like the birds the birds that are
they're singing in the doc's room and he
just kept thinking he kept hearing these
songs
you know he
heard the saying he just didn't
just didn't make it
remember that
i never uh
hey
i've never been scared before ruth
there it is
okay
that's okay
that's okay
you're okay
hey hey
what's she like out there what does she
like out there
dido was what's she
like and that was like
like a horse i never thought i'd ever
get to ride
you know i never felt
i never felt worthy of riding a horse
you know she's she's the she's the first
horse i've ever had that made me wish i
was a jockey
hey there's still time for you oh yeah
you know there's uh
you get older you
you start to realize that uh
you know you and your body
they just ain't the same
you know what i mean
i think this might be my last season
ruth
all right it's coming back
let me help you get up on the couch
no
let's just sit here for a while longer
can we
thank you everyone for joining us my
name is carlos aguilar i'm a film critic
here in los angeles and it's my pleasure
to be here today to talk about jock in
this particular scene
with the director of the film clint
bentley producer greg creedar
and the stars clifton collins jr and
molly parker thank you guys for joining
us
thanks for having us yeah yeah um so
we'll you know in terms of the specific
scene which is sort of like a pivotal
moment for
you know for jackson
and root's relationship and sort of
looking at you know
what his body is sort of like doing to
him and and you know what things are out
for him uh why don't we start with you
clint and greg in terms of the writing
of this scene and what you wanted to
express uh about this character with
this moment it really it's it's it's a
wonderful scene because it's got both
uh both the promise of everything that's
that's really coming together about
their relationship and after all this
time and all of their hopes and dreams
um and also the the possibilities of
what they can achieve with this horse
and then the reality of where uh
clifton's or jackson's body is actually
at
um through this through this moment and
um just seeing those juxtaposed that was
a big thing we wanted to
to play with
and for me i think it's just what what's
so profound about this this scene
um and it got so elevated through
working with the with the clifton and
molly and and and our team but
you know at its core it's jackson
finally having to reveal his pain to
someone else and his fear
and that being the thing that when a
jockey knows their time is done is when
when they finally have to uh embrace
that they're that they have fear that's
a thing that a jockey can't have and
and it's all the emotions of the movie
wrapped into this little trailer with
these two people where we feel their
history of what was the reality of what
is the tragedy of what could have been
clifton you know you you spend so much
time with real jockeys in this track and
sort of learning about their lives and
their one day view or channeling some of
you know the things that they share with
you and sort of the pain both emotional
physical that that they undergo in this
profession
um
there's a lot of a lot of uh hanging out
with the jockeys and just uh
you know sharing war stories i've got my
war stories and they've got their war
stories
obviously i'm more interested in their
stories
but also this is something that i had to
be very conscious of through the
through the course of this characterism
arc
in the film um
the the disease in his body breaks down
over time
so at this particular point um
[Music]
it's a painful it's a painful moment
because it's something you don't want to
let go of
um it's it's your sole purpose for many
of these jockeys and the rush
you know a lot of these guys come from a
lineage of people so
um
for me it was uh the research of
injuries
um rehabilitation things of that nature
um just uh
a lot of youtube videos and stuff like
that and just kind of hearing of
everybody else's journeys and just
taking little pieces of that and kind of
carving it into the
into the pain
that that
that grows and escalates to to this
final moment that you see
and it is also a moment in which he has
to be vulnerable in front of a of
another person so i wonder you know
having had it you know having molly
there uh playing root uh change or so
the dynamic or or helped you express
those emotions um having molly parker
opposite you and any scenes gonna help
you with any emotions
truth toll
um and yes it was super helpful um
we spent a lot of time together
uh every night going over the scenes and
exploring the emotions of the characters
and what they're going through
so
um
you know this is also a moment that
comes on the on the tail end of a
celebration because we did win because
we are on top
because uh we have overcome so many odds
so there's a a lot of emotions that
happen
that kind of get away from you because
at this age in the game
i don't think one really one hopes for
but
you don't know
when that when's going to happen albeit
it felt good in the moment
and you it's easy to suspect
it needs to be extra hopeful with this
kind of horse
and in this particular moment so
um working opposite um molly in this
scene is uh
i mean it's just a magical moment i i
felt very safe
you know being vulnerable with their um
which
kind of bites me a little bit i guess
one could say i don't know maybe it
doesn't but uh
um yeah it did feel very safe it was the
kind of scene you just didn't want to
end
you know it was a scene that you just
could have just kept going and going and
going
right molly what do you think this scene
says about the relationship between
jackson and ruth
yeah i love the scene and we actually
shot it right at the end i think it was
one of the last things we shot so in a
way for me it contains kind of all of
those aspects of
yeah i think what clifton and i were
kind of hoping to to create and show
which is this
long friendship that has
complications because they
are employer employee
they
have
maybe a past
romantic relationship or future or you
know we don't really know but it has all
of those layers
and i think that you know the horse this
like
incredible horse has
has reignited something certainly in
ruth that that was asleep or maybe she
thought was just over you know at this
point in her life and her career and
so we've come out of this celebration of
like oh god there's this possibility
that maybe
maybe we could
win and there's this high that they're
on that i
you know i think clifton and i were just
really
consciously and unconsciously trying to
create a lot of joy at the beginning of
the scene and and
and then so so then when he when when
he has this attack of whatever is going
on with him it's um
yeah it's it's that much more
heartbreaking because
he has to be vulnerable with her
and she's the one person he really
doesn't want to tell the truth to
because if if he says it out loud to her
he knows it's over you know
and to say
you know i was never scared before i'm
scared um
is to admit you can't do it anymore you
know and and so yeah this i love this
scene it was fun so fun and there's you
know
somehow we had this weird little cat in
there too
he just showed up
so there was there were a lot there was
a lot of magic going on it was pretty
pretty cool
i mean there's also some wonderful
dialogue in this scene and i wonder if
you know first greg and clint can talk
about the writing of that and then you
know we could hear from clifton about
how much that changed or if you changed
it all from from what was on the page it
was something that the the scene really
breaking it into two halves uh the first
part where
they're just having fun and dancing
around and and jackson's looking for
clean glasses and molly's
uh
just pulling cards out and things like
that
um
really they created that part of the
scene the scene as it was written in
that section
was just uh you know they have a good
time and dance in the trailer and then
it really led into this the the second
section after jackson falls where it's
really heavily scripted
and then at that point we had we had all
worked together quite a bit um greg and
me and and molly and clifton
for days up to that scene of really
getting it right and cutting out the
things that we had written that that
were bad and there's one in particular
that um
you know where he says
uh
ruth asked jackson how it felt writing
on diodo's lament um and he says i never
felt worthy of a horse like that and
that was something that was a different
line
for that moment his answer was a
different line as written but it just
didn't feel right
and then we all talked about it in the
moment and that line of i didn't feel
worthy i've never felt worthy before of
a horse like that
really
kind of brought out a theme of the movie
that i don't know that any of us really
thought was there
of of
um hoping to be worthy of something
better than what you have now
clifton what is your your process to to
sort of make these awards your own and
and deliver them in such a beautiful way
um so it was a build up those emotions
and
and and talking them out every night as
well
um so slowly allowing myself just to
kind of walk in and let the moment
happen and and let those um emotions
ring out because uh there's moments that
happen in that scene that um
that don't really traditionally happen
that way
in the uh in the realm of like how
emotions can humans express themselves
and in order to do that you kind of have
to um
kind of have to go a little deep and it
hurts so
molly what is your take on on dialogue
and sort of like making it seem so
effortless and
natural between the two characters
you know i i don't
typically really enjoy doing improv
on camera and i and i don't mostly
because it it just makes me feel
self-conscious and takes me out of the
moment
because i'm thinking about
i'm thinking when i don't want to be
thinking
you know this movie was shot with a crew
of 10 and we were all sort of
staying
at this little hotel near the track so
we had this opportunity to
get together every night and look at the
stuff we were going to do the next day
and really
go through it and so in that way things
would get um
you know choices would be made but there
was still room and then because
because we were working on a live track
and we were around
you know it was really we came to it we
weren't bringing it to us and so i think
so yeah i don't know
and in some ways i don't i remember the
scene i don't remember how we
did it you know i remember being in it
and that's maybe just a good good sign
yeah yeah i i can't overstate just like
how we didn't want that euphoria to end
um of that first half of the scene it
was molly's last night and she brought
she bring brought that energy to every
day of the set that we we kept writing
more for her to do and and and the
character kept growing uh with the life
of its own and
and you know literally we're in this
this this trailer this airstream and you
know clint and i are cramped into a
little bathtub in the in the back while
they're doing this thing in the first
half scene and it just kept we just kept
going and kept rolling because and
really and once we came to edit this it
was this was the first scene that we
really
had you know it it caught so effortless
effortlessly and and then once we had it
we knew
that the whole movie was encapsulated in
within what was happening in the scene
and and it became the standard bearer
for the rest that kind of like okay if
the rest of me can live up to what's
happening here
um we will have a we'll really have a
movie clifton when you're in a scene
like this how do you you come into us in
some emotional intense like this
we were pretty much on the same page i
think that helps a lot when you have
everybody thinking and feeling more or
less where you're going
um
it adds to the uh
the element of just the cinematic magic
that you hope for
that single tear
oh go ahead
i was going to say the same thing
do it you do it you do it i'll brag on
clifton because he won't do it himself
with these emotional scenes this one in
particular
but throughout the movie
he would have it he would be there by
take one or take two that you know
as a director you've got it and you
don't really have to you don't really
have to worry about it from that point
on
and then yes as greg was pointing out
somehow he's also able to
be as conscious of the light in the
camera as anybody else's yeah um and
just drop a single tear
at just the right moment to the camera
that's that's very impressive
it's it is what i i'm going to pile on
just because the you know what
what makes him great is it's not just
his ability to inhabit it fully and be
in it and shut off from the rest and
it's also that he's a storyteller so
that he is aware
of all the other aspects of the things
that are going on around him and
and so each scene it's it's not just
about what he feels it's about the story
that's being told
uh on the whole and and that yeah that
that just makes him one of the one of
the great actors of my generation i
think
that's incredible um i want to thank you
all for being here thank you everyone
for watching thank you clifton thank you
claim molly greg
and hope that you guys enjoyed the film
thank you everyone thank you carlos